he is Tom Curren Tom Curren joining us
now he covers the Patriots of course for
NBC Sports Boston Tommy how are you this
morning
I'm spectacular ly average but improving
yeah it's national cheeseburger day we
got the Trager grill fired up what could
be better than that and talking to you I
would say a double stack cheeseburger on
the trigger grill well done I mean I
mean no pun intended but yeah you're
right
that that sounds good we might do that
by the way I was reading some of your
tweets and your column where didn't
sound like you were in the front of the
line there for the Patriots getting Josh
Gordon so explain to the audience your
thoughts now that the Patriots have Josh
Gordon how this will work out well the
reason I wasn't excuse me is because if
you look at I mean the train has left
the station
Padme train has left the station the
season has started this is one of the
best teams in the AFC certainly perhaps
the NFL and they're strapped at the wide
receiver position if you want to bear
with me for 30 seconds of logic the
Patriots didn't trade Jimmy Garoppolo
because they wanted to make sure that
they didn't get caught short at the
quarterback position so they end up
settling for a second-round pick they
just drop them off on the stoop over in
San Francisco meanwhile before the draft
there was such an C to move on from
Brandon cooks so that they could have
draft collateral that they traded him
before the draft 401 and at that time
all they really had in house was Julian
Edelman
krisily hopefully Jordan Matthews then
Kenny Britt Malcolm Mitchell coming back
from an injury in the Attic cordarrelle
Patterson there was just a Whitney of
question marks there but I feel that
because in their haste to move on from
crooks who's a really good player not
unbelievable but good player
they caught themselves short Mitchell
didn't he end up being able to play this
year Patterson's unable to really
immerse himself in the offense Matthews
didn't make the team
Bricka cut because of a hamstring
Edelman gets suspended so now you're
sifting through the junk drawer of the
Cleveland Browns and Buffalo Bills and
yes Josh go
unbelievable and I wish him the best
it'll be fun as hell if he does well did
but advanced planning could have had the
Patriots looking at this insane yeah
he's a great player but he's not
dependable instead they're gonna depend
on him how was that it's good
yeah I didn't know Jimmy Garoppolo would
factor into this but he is everything I
did think well we've already talked
about that that I still don't believe
that that's all you got for Jimmy
Garoppolo but the Brandon cooks angle is
interesting as well because I thought
you had somebody who gave you a deep
threat and something that the Patriots
did not have we didn't know Edelman was
gonna be suspended
you know Gronk you know you resign him
and you would still have the elements of
having a printing throw and Hogan that's
a pretty you know capable wide receiving
course so why why did they give up on
Brandon cooks because he was entering
the final year of his contract and they
were not going to resign him to the
insane money that the last Angeles Rams
signed them to which I get I understand
that's fine if you want to get some
recompense for that player but you have
to have the position locked down
previously which to me they're
inconsistent in that they didn't
maximize Jimmy Garoppolo that's that's
why I bring Garoppolo in if you
maximized him at a position that you
really didn't need to worry about backup
quarterback as you can see the Brian
Hoyer there if you maximize the return
on him then you wouldn't have to try and
maximize return on Brandon cooks so that
to me they wanted to get compensation
for him my contention is get
compensation for the other guy who
really can draw a lot of compensation
you put a for sale sign on them what do
you expect out when does Gordon show up
and is there a chance he plays on Monday
night he still needs to have a physical
B Sunday night then you know Sunday
night isn't it no no Sunday night I keep
saying Monday night so Sunday night
watching Sunday Night Football anymore
come on
I think that he's doing he still hasn't
had his physical that's why Bill
Belichick was reticent to say that
things were were done in to comment on
him even though both teams signed a
release bill they hadn't talked about a
man like okay this guy know what he's
getting into
no no no I don't think that he's known
what he's getting into
I mean I think that he lives life not
knowing what he's getting into
yeah unfortunately and you know this
there's a level of sympathy you can have
an empathy you can have for somebody
who's struggling with addiction and
substance abuse but this is no longer
the fault of the Cleveland Browns of the
NFL rules or anything else this the
balls in Josh Gordon's court you know
people compare him to Randy Moss and I
understand talent wise but Randy Moss
had a career that was brilliant
Josh Gordon had a season five years ago
yeah so you know I I I do know the Tom
Brady's patience level for players who
are not dependable is low
doesn't matter how talented you are how
high you can jump around fast you are so
you know if he's not sure that Josh
Gordon is going to be where josh gordon
is supposed to be on a particular route
doesn't matter how fast he gets to where
he's not supposed to be talking to Tom
Curren of NBC Sports Boston covers the
Patriots with the Patriots have made
this moon had they beaten Jacksonville I
think so yeah I definitely especially
the nature of the way you know if you
just call the score 27 26 or 27 24 in
the England wins that wouldn't have
taken away the difficulty they're having
at the wide receiver position
when Edelman comes back things will be
different and I believe that that's
probably the wait till I'm Brady feels
as well you can now devote two players
to Rob Gronkowski and James White is
your second best skill position player
it's not horrible but he's a pass
catching back who's gonna have to make
15 people mess to get chunks of yardage
so I think when Edelman comes back it'll
help to take heat off of Gronkowski
it'll it'll open more things up for him
but in the meantime they don't have that
outside threat because cordarrelle
Patterson you watch me the highlights
from from Sunday's game they
trust them to run many routes beyond the
line of scrimmage and look at him they
just throw him you know tear screens and
jailbreak screens at the line of
scrimmage because they want to take
advantage of of his speed but the
downfield stuff they haven't
incorporated him in any chance that
Brady gives up the number 12 to Josh
Gordon no little-known fact
Josh Gordon has a giant tattoo of
himself wearing the number 12 on his
back but so does Brady
well no Brady has a tattoo of Josh
Gordon on his back wearing number 12 do
you one up see yeah I did topper topper
will Josh Gordon finished the season as
a patriot Tom Curren oh boy that's great
that's a growl I'm gonna put that up as
a poll question right here on Twitter
right now I'm in a vote no I'm voting no
no he will not something will happen
however benign something will happen
good to talk to you Tom this was
terrific thing let's do it again okay
that's a Tom Curren Patriots insider NBC
Sports Boston not Tommy Kern Tom
Iker for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]